amazon's private label amazon basics
is coming under fire for stealing
another company's design for a backpack
yeah there it is yeah it's pretty
serious it's also
not the first time the amazon basics
brand has been accused of stealing an
idea
and that includes their brand new amazon
basics streaming service
check it out hi america is amazon basics
now launching a brand new streaming
service with all the biggest hits heck
yeah
because with the new amazon basics prime
video we're talking all the best
buzzworthy shows like
fred lasso that is them
black ask and order and law
the unit for not not special victims
plus grandma favorites circle of
monies 3 600 seconds
plus all the shows you love to binge the
workplace
pals and howdy
greg and don't forget all our hit movies
like
living dinosaur plays the quick and the
qualified
and the next tim croy's blockbuster
agenda unpossible seven
completely original non-stolen content
only from
amazon basics prime video
we're loving it